[Music]
we're in the midst of insecure how
secure are we about this season I'm very
secure about this season I love the
stories that we're telling I know like
we're filming as you know and our actors
are killing it Jane Yvonne I don't know
if they've got here yet but they are
killing it this okay how many times has
ISA cried gotten upset so far this
season
I'm trying to gauge to see maybe where
this relationship is I'm trying to find
out some things on the road and I want
you guys to be surprised we have real
the writers couldn't work this season
we've got like we're really staying true
to life you know I hope you guys are
satisfied do you feel like though an
extra pressure like we really got to
bring it I mean Golden Globe nominations
all of that in your first season II
believe it or not I don't I feel like I
feel the pressure around me you know I
feel like people are like you gotta come
come back you gotta come correct but I
just want to tell a good progressive
story and I'm feel confident that we've
done that but I don't think you're gonna
expect like huge twists and turns
looking like that are you not coming
home
course we are not about to be the black
couple fighting in writing I just need
to know if y'all get back together I'm
rooting for I know there were issues I'm
not sure if infidelity is a deal breaker
if not the women right a lot of women
stay with their men he's cheating but a
lot of men are like nah I'm out I could
find somebody else exact so that's
interesting it's an interesting
discussion
you